hola ya con más tiempo voy a resolver
este problema 13 que por cierto está en
la página 491 y el problema 13 me dice a
algo así el precio del teléfono aumentó
en un principio el 10 por ciento después
este nuevo presión de creció en un 25% y
lo que me preguntan es qué porcentaje es
el precio final del precio inicial y
bueno pues vamos a ver cómo resuelve
este problema el precio final el precio
final del teléfono a quienes igual bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que el precio
inicial pero al precio inicial lo vamos
a aumentar en un 10% cuando nosotros
aumentamos en un 10% una cierta cantidad
realmente lo que estamos haciendo es
multiplicándolo por 1.1 es decir estamos
aumentando le al cien por ciento el 10%
más para así obtener el precio aumentado
en un 10% por lo tanto el primer precio
que vamos a obtener es el
x 1.1 pero después este nuevo precio
decrece un 25% y si te crece en un 25%
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar a
esta cantidad a todo esto que está aquí
por punto 75 cuando lo multiplicó por
punto 75 lo que estoy haciendo es
decrecer este precio en un 25% esta
cantidad que teníamos la voy a decrecer
en un 75% y vamos a ver cuánto es esto
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
multiplicar 1.1 por puntos 75 para ver
el porcentaje real en el cual cambio el
precio inicial
vamos a ver 5 por 11 el 55 después aquí
pongo un 0 7 por 11 es 77 y después voy
a poner esto aquí abajo en me queda 5 +
5 y 7 son 12 y llevamos unam 7 y unas
son 8 y recorre el punto 3 veces
entonces 123 me va a quedar justo aquí y
entonces puedo decir que el precio final
del tel
es exactamente lo mismo que el precio
inicial del teléfono x punto 825 o dicho
de otra manera si lo que nos preguntan
es qué porcentaje es el precio final del
precio inicial pues ya este porcentaje
lo multiplicó por 100 el precio final es
el 82.5 por ciento el precio inicial del
precio inicial y ya está por cierto este
es el inciso c de esta pregunta y así de
fácil y así de sencillo obtengo este
resultado multiplicando 1.1 que es el
10% aumentado por el punto 75 que es el
25% disminuido y ya está entonces vamos
a resolver el siguiente problema déjenme
borrar este pesar vano y curiosamente
justo esto es lo que yo hago en mi
trabajo me dedico a fondos de inversión
y no tienes una idea de cómo utilizó el
porcentaje siempre hay que están
multiplicando y sacando porcentajes de
cosas y bueno lo único que puedo decir
es que es muy útil así que vamos a ver
el siguiente proyecto
problema número 14 14 estoy poniendo
primero el 4 muy bien 14 dice cuando el
número w está multiplicado por cuatro
el resultado es exactamente lo mismo que
cuando a cuatro le sumo w a ver vamos a
ver esto dice cuando el número de w está
multiplicado por cuatro
pues bueno pues esos cuatro w cuatro w
esto es exactamente lo mismo que cuando
a cuatro le sumo w que cuatro sumado con
w muy bien y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale tres veces doble
y bueno esto está muy sencillo porque
para resolver este problema
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
quitar w de ambos lados de esta ecuación
voy a restar w aquí voy a restar w de
este lado también y que me va a quedar
bueno del lado izquierdo 4 w
doble un estrés doble un justo lo que yo
quiero y del otro lado me va a quedar 4
+ w
y estos dos se van y me queda simple y
sencillamente 43 w es igual a 4 así de
fácil y así de sencillo recuerda que en
este tipo de ejercicios no es necesario
despejar a w
tal vez utilizando una manipulación
algebraica puedes obtener de una manera
muy sencilla lo que te piden en este
caso 3 w así que aquí me acabe el
problema número 15 y vamos a hacer aquí
nuestro problema número 15 dice la
longitud de los lados de un triángulo
rectángulo la longitud de los lados de
un triángulo rectángulo tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo eso es importante
son enteros pares consecutivos
fascinante esto está increíble a ver
déjame poner un triángulo rectángulo por
aquí este va a ser uno de mis lados a
este por aquí por acá tengo otro de mis
lados
voy a suponer este por acá y aquí tengo
la hipotenusa
este es mi tramo del rectángulo que por
cierto aquí tengo un ángulo recto y dice
si el menor de estos enteros pares
consecutivos es x que ecuación podemos
usar para resolver x
bueno supongamos que este es el lado más
pequeño y entonces este lado vale x pero
sabemos que sus lados son enteros x es
un entero son pares y consecutivos pues
el entero par que les diga x es a este
sumarle 2 es decir este lado va a valer
x + 2 y el lado más grande que recuerda
que siempre en un triángulo rectángulo
la hipotenusa es el lado más grande va a
valer el consecutivo de éste es decir x
+ 4
y bueno si yo lo que quiero es encontrar
una ecuación que me relacione estos tres
lados para obtener el valor de x
podemos utilizar el teorema de pitágoras
y el teorema de pitágoras me dice que si
elevamos un lado al cuadrado el primer
cateto el cateto x elevado al cuadrado
ya esto le sumamos el otro cateto
elevado al cuadrado más x más 2 elevado
al cuadrado esto tiene que ser
exactamente lo mismo que la hipotenusa
elevada al cuadrado en todos los
triángulos rectángulos debe de pasar
esto x cuadrado más x más 2 elevado al
cuadrado eso tiene que ser igual a la
hipotenusa elevada al cuadrado a x más 4
elevado al cuadrado y déjame ver si
tenemos que simplificar esto o trabajar
esta ecuación
x cuadrada + x2 elevado al cuadrado esto
es igual a x 4 elevado al cuadrado
perfecto esto es el inciso c así que ya
no necesito hacerle más a esta ecuación
ya está aquí mi respuesta y si te das
cuenta estos son los problemas sencillos
de esta sección
vamos a hacer el siguiente problema ya
que estos están muy sencillos vamos a
trabajar con el problema número 16 que
me dice lo siguiente dice si x es más
grande que uno si x es más grande que
uno esto por una parte y que es
exactamente igual que x más 1 entre x
más 1 entre x entonces nos preguntan
cuál de las siguientes afirmaciones es
verdadera
y me ponen el número uno es que ya no es
igual que x el número 2 me dicen que ya
es entero
entero y es entero y el número 3 me dice
que x porque esto es más grande que x
cuadrado muy bien vamos a ver cuál de
éstos es cierto y bueno creo que de una
manera muy rápida nos podemos dar cuenta
que este no es cierto que el número 2 no
es cierto y es entero imagínate que
equivale 2 si x es igual a 2 estoy
tomando un número más grande que uno
entonces a 2 más un medio esto es lo
mismo que ya esto no es un entero esto
es lo mismo que dos enteros un medio y
bueno esto no es un número entero por lo
tanto a esta afirmación no es cierta
esta de aquí no es cierta vamos a ver si
puedo probar los demás a intentemos
probar el número 3 x porque tiene que
ser más grande que x cuadrada vamos a
ver que me quedan al multiplicar x por
james x por james es lo mismo que
multiplicar esta parte por x que es x
cuadrada + 1 / x por x pues esto es lo
mismo que 1 y esto es claramente más
grande que x cuadrada esto es más grande
que x cuadrada porque cuando yo me tomo
una x y lo elevó al cuadrado ya esto le
sumó 1 siempre va a ser más grande que
ese mismo número elevado al cuadrado
aquí estoy sumando 1 aquí no estoy
sumando nada por lo tanto siempre es más
grande sumar 1 que no sumar nada o
inclusive lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera si yo restó x cuadrada de ambos
lados de esta desigualdad
me quedaría que uno es más grande que
cero lo cual es cierto entonces bueno el
inciso 3 si se cumple esta es cierta muy
bien y después el inciso 1 me dice que
quien no puede ser lo mismo que x y esto
creo que tiene toda la lógica del mundo
sí que es igual a x + 1 entre x
esto no puede ser exactamente igual que
equis y más si pensamos que quizás más
grande que uno vamos a ver si lo podemos
probar vamos a suponer que si son
iguales me quedaría que x es exactamente
lo mismo que x más 1 entre x y ahora si
restó x de ambos lados desde igualdad me
va a quedar que es 0 es igual a 1 entre
x y no hay ninguna x mayor que 1 ninguna
que hay que ponerla aquí me sea igual a
0 porque aquí tenemos un pedazo de un
pastel dividido en x rebanadas y esto no
es igual a 0 porque no estamos tomando
una rebanada y una rebanada no es igual
a 0 rebanadas o 1 sobre x nunca va a ser
igual a 0 por lo tanto esto no es lo
mismo por lo tanto esto no es lo mismo y
por lo tanto ya no es lo mismo que
por lo tanto este también es cierto la
afirmación 1 y 3 son ciertas y esto es
el insisto de perfecto y que crees ya
con esto acabamos los problemas de la
sección número 9 y de hecho los
problemas del examen número dos ya tengo
aquí la solución de todos estos
problemas porque solamente eran 16 en la
sección número 9 así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo donde vamos a empezar un
nuevo examen y una nueva sección nos
vemos en el siguiente